bring it to the runway category is stars
statements and legends tens
tens tens across the board tj start the
music
if you love fashion beauty pop culture
and a healthy dose of drama
rupaul's drag race is for you it's won a
whopping 19 emmys since it premiered in
2009
and the reality tv juggernaut is as
funny as it is heartfelt
giving queer performers a chance to
shine drag was an
un really an untapped phenomenon that
spoke
volumes about the human experience and
about our culture
and about you know punk rock and anarchy
and
identity it had so many different layers
of information and entertainment i knew
there was something
interesting i didn't know it would be
you know a worldwide phenomenon like
it has become
[Music]
what are you doing here diva i thought i
fired you not that i
know of oh that was the other gay guy i
really need to stop getting the two of
you confused
season two of the netflix comedy special
started streaming last month
ryan o'connell who serves as the creator
executive producer writer and star of
the emmy nominated series
adapted the concept from his 2015 memoir
which chronicles his experiences
as a gay man living with cerebral palsy
i think when we first went and pitched
like a gay disabled show let's just say
the execs weren't foaming at the mouth
strangers come up to me at the gym and
congratulate me simply for exercising
it's super inspiring to see you give it
your all
despite your limitations ill inspiration
porn
is that what that is but like to me i
always knew that it was a very universal
story a story about an underdog a story
about an outsider
it just came in an unconventional
package but it's a top 40 pop song don't
get it twisted
richard it's a sin available now on
amazon prime video canada
is an incredible critically acclaimed
british miniseries that follows a group
of gay men living through the uk's hiv
aids crisis
from 1981 to 1991. there was a whole
range of responses and
lots of people who lived through this
time had no idea what was going on
because so much of it happened in
silence
and what i'm hoping is it encourages the
conversation and people really recognize
and acknowledge how far we have come
and that living with hiv now you on
effective treatment you have a normal
life healthy life
and you can't pass the virus on
is this about your legacy no it's about
our legacy
and although pose recently came to an
end the fx series will be remembered
particularly for its representation i
hope that
young queer people of all colors
can look at me and know
[Music]
that they can the predominantly african
american and latino lgbtq plus cast
included a variety of trans actors who
helped accurately portray the
underground ballroom scene of the 80s
and 90s
the show demonstrates the perspective of
a very marginalized group
that is rarely hurt people don't know
what the experiences of trans people
are so it shows an incredible
opportunity to create connections
between
a very marginalized group of people and
the audience that
cares to watch